But even though the unsupervised learning problem isn't really that crisply
defined, we can define a basic clustering problem and, and be somewhat
crisp about it. So, that's what I want to do next.
I want to say that one of the classic unsupervised problems is
clustering, taking a set of objects and putting them into groups.
And so, here's what we're going to assume. We're going to assume that we're
given some set of objects X and we're given information about
how they relate to each other in the form of inter-object distances.
So we're going to assume that for objects x and y in the set of
objects we have D(x,y) which is the same as D(y,x). Which says how far apart
they are in, in some space. Now they don't actually have to be in
some metric space. They just need to have this, this distance matrix D to find.
>> So that makes sense, now let me ask you,
so you said they don't have to be in a metric
space. So you mean it literally does not have to be
a real distance? It doesn't have to be a, a metric.
>> Yeah, I don't, I don't think
we're going to depend on that. I think we just need
some kind of way of measuring how far apart things are. And
it doesn't mean that they're embedded in some two dimensional space or
three dimensional space. There's just numbers that relate them to one another.
>> So they don't have to obey the triangle inequality, for example.
>> I don't think so. I don't think we're going to depend on that in any way.
>> Okay. So this is just like KNN because everything is
like KNN. Where you have this notion of similarity and distance and
that's where your domain knowledge is. So you've got a bunch of
objects and your domain knowledge is
these distances, these similarities between objects.
>> Exactly, right. And in fact it's, it's surprisingly
similar to KNN in that they surprisingly depend on similarness.
>> Hm. So that's good. So KNN is similar to everything, so
its distance is small to all things. [LAUGH] Wow, that is very meta.
>> Alright. So that's, that's the input and
the output that a clustering algorithm needs to,
to create is a partition. Which is to say
we're going to, I'll write it this way. That P
of, P sub D. The partition function defined for
some particular distance set D, for, for some object
x, is just going to be some label, but it's such that if x and y are going to be
assigned to the same cluster, the same partition, then
they're going to have the same output of this PD function.
>> Okay.
>> That make some sense?
>> That does make sense.
>> What would be a trivial clustering
algorithm based on this definition? Right, it's
taking its input the objects and then
the distances. And then it spits out partitions.
>> A trivial one would be, well, a trivial
one would be put everything in the same partition.
>> Yeah. So that would be one. So that would
be, that would look like this. P, for all x in
the set of objects, PD of x equals, let's say,
1. So that means that all objects are in partition 1.
>> We're all humans.
>> That's right.
>> Okay. Here's another trivial one. Every
single object is in its own partition.
>> Yes, good, that's the other one I was
thinking of. Which maybe we could write like this. We'll
just use the object name itself as the name
of of the cluster. And now every object is in
its own cluster. Now, we didn't define, as part
of this, this problem definition, whether we should like the
one where everybody's in the same cluster or the
one that everyone's in different clusters or something in between,
it's not really in the, in this definition at this level of detail.
>> Hm. Well, that's fine. I mean, we can all be humans
and we can all be unique snowflakes at the same time. [LAUGH]